six months ago a handful of billionaire
oligarchs in silicon valley decided to
censor
and ostracize the duly elected sitting
president of the united states
now president trump is fighting back by
suing
big tech to reinstate his social media
accounts
i just want to say that i stand before
you
this morning to announce a very
important
and very beautiful i think development
for
our freedom and our freedom of speech
and that goes to all americans
today in conjunction with the america
first
policy institute i'm filing as the
lead class representative a major class
action lawsuit against the big tech
giants including facebook
google and twitter as well as their ceos
mark zuckerberg sunder buche
and jack dorsey three real nice guys
our case will prove this
censorship is unlawful it's
unconstitutional and it's
completely un-american we all know that
we all know that
very very well the squishes
hate this lawsuit i love
this lawsuit and it's got a lot more
merit than people are giving
president trump credit for trump is
suing the big tech
billionaires for censoring him the
question that a lot of people are asking
is
is this really a free speech issue
well there are really two questions here
is it a first amendment issue
and is it a free speech issue because
it's not it's
same broad topic but they're actually
different questions so there
are lawyers who are rather expert in
this field i'm thinking of
alan dershowitz former professor
emeritus at harvard law school
i'm thinking of eugene vollock a really
really prominent lawyer and commentator
who say you know maybe this lawsuit
does have some merit on first amendment
grounds maybe it's a big maybe they'll
have to prove it in court
is this a free speech issue absolutely
absolutely i think the days of build
your own twitter twit google's a private
company
they can do whatever they want build
your own facebook or whatever that's
over first of all they won't let us
build our own twitter
we tried we've tried to do that several
times and they just won't let us do it
second of all if
you control the speech of a democratic
republic
if you and let's say two of your buddies
in silicon valley
control who are the guys that's we've
got hipster rasputin you've got jack
dorsey
you've got mark zuckerberg and then
you've got in president trump's words
sundar
and i love that president trump did not
even take the time to learn his name
he's the head of google
but if you if you and your two buddies
control
the flow of information around the
internet if you control ninety percent
of speech in the
digital realm which is the public square
now you are by definition engaging in a
political act
because in a democratic republic speech
is politics and politics a speech this
is the theme of my book
speechless which is available now as
many of you have heard so
you are even if you're you don't work
for the government
you don't frankly google and face and
facebook
and probably twitter for that matter
have a cozier relationship
with the government than i think many
people are aware of but even if they did
not even if they just pretended to be
totally private companies
if you are controlling the speech around
a republic you are engaged in a
political act
and the people have a right to have a
say in that political process
like mitch mcconnell said as
establishmentarian man as mitch
mcconnell
he said a corporation
can act like a parallel government and
in this case
the the those corporations in silicon
valley are even less accountable to the
people
than than the jokesters in in washington
dc
so this absolutely is a free speech
issue this i think is the defining issue
of our time i think it's more important
than immigration
i think it's more important than tax
cuts i think it's more important than
whatever is going on in iran and syria
this is the issue that will determine
who rules us and how we are ruled
hey yo you you gotta subscribe you gotta
like
you gotta comment you gotta engage i
want your engagement you can watch this
whole episode by the way
uh which is called donald trump versus
hipster rasputin you can catch it here
you can catch it on apple podcast
spotify google play stitcher
myspace zanga all over the place you can
also get my book speechless
controlling words controlling ones
number one national bestseller thanks to
wonderful readers
like you let me know what you think
about it see you next time
[Music]
[Music]